howard do you know something funny about
sal when we do these zoom meetings work
meetings like
most of the time his camera is full of
vape smoke he can't even see him
he's like vaping up a storm now
it's like we're in a jazz club that's
what you see
that's not even it looks like a magic
show and i just appear after the smoke
dissolves so you really can't get off
that thing huh
i can't howard i mean and lately you
know with this whole culvert thing it's
been so stressful so
i i've been i've been vaping more and um
what happens like you wake up in the
morning and you say i gotta quit
vaping i know that's a big thing with
you you know i don't want your lungs
you know if you get cold your lungs are
compromised from vaping and then you
wake up and you go you know what i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna vape
and then at what point do you break down
like almost immediately
uh probably within a half hour right
yeah
so you're only strong for about a half
hour and then you become the weakling
that you are right
and what does your brain say to you your
brain goes don't do it sal don't do it
and then what do you say to your brain
like
no i'm going to do it i'm going to like
is there any debate going on like take
us in no
my brain doesn't say a thing i got i'm
honest
so you're one of those rare individuals
that doesn't have any kind of brain
that says anything to you whenever you
it doesn't say a thing
it doesn't say that i mean i look at it
this way like i'm telling myself you
know you have to quit you have to quit
you have to quit and then when i pick it
up
i just shut my brain down because i
don't i guess i don't want my brain to
tell me i need to quit
my brain talks too much that's the
problem i'm trying to slow it down
but when i pick up my baby i'm not
talking at all to talking too much
why did you tell us your brain doesn't
talk to you and now you're saying your
brain talks too much
i shut up my brain therefore it doesn't
talk to me
it talks to me in other words you say to
your brain shut up
yes richard's right you have like two
brains in other words
the man with two brains i don't have
no brains now i have two i'm pretty
amazing two brains
and after the vape does the brain try to
start talking again or it just
shuts up uh moves on to other things
right both brains
doesn't tell you yeah yeah i'm curious
oh we have notes on that
oh yeah we have no i was busy talking
the rabbits and butterflies and god
knows what else is going on
i saw a butterfly the other day and then
he started questioning what are the
purpose
what is the purpose of butterflies like
you just went down this like
philosophical road that's your brain
would you share with us i mean there
there's so much bad in the world yet at
the same time howard there's there's so
many beautiful things that we take for
granted
and uh when i see the butterfly i'm like
you know what there
is a lot of good here we just have to
stop and look and see
what is around us what this universe has
given us and we have look at richard
i imagine that poor butterfly flying
through his vape smoke
choking to death
you